ليس الأمر كله في رأسك ، فبعض
الناس أكثر جاذبية للبعوض
أكثر من غيرهم ، وقد حددت الأبحاث أن
الأمر يتعلق بكيفية شم رائحة كل منا
والتي تكون فردية لكل شخص ويتم
تحديدها جزئيًا بواسطة التوائم المتآخية في الحمض النووي.
من التوائم المتطابقة من
حيث الحمض النووي والرائحة ، لذلك أجرى الخبراء في لندن
دراسة بين
التوائم المتماثلة والتوائم المتماثلة لمعرفة ما إذا
كان هناك فرق بين الاثنين
عندما عرّضوا التوائم
للبعوض ووجدوا أن
التوائم المتطابقة قد تعرضت للعض بكميات مماثلة.  ولكن
تم عض التوائم الشقيقة بكميات مختلفة
مما يعني أن البعوض
يلدغ بعض الأفراد أكثر من
غيرهم وهذا على الأقل جزئيًا
بسبب رائحة الجسم لدى
العلماء بالفعل إحساس بالمركبات الموجودة في الروائح البشرية التي
تجذب البعوض ويأملون
في تطوير عقار  يغير
روائح جسم الإنسان لجعلها أقل
جاذبية للبعوض مما قد يكون له
فوائد صحية عامة كبيرة  خاصة في
المناطق التي ينقل فيها البعوض أمراضًا
مثل الملاريا وحمى الضنك وفيروس غرب النيل